[Music]
introduction of artificial intelligence
and machine learning
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to define artificial intelligence
describe the relationship between
artificial intelligence and data science
define machine learning describe the
relationship between machine learning
artificial intelligence and data science
describe different machine learning
approaches identify the applications of
machine learning let's understand how
the field of artificial intelligence
emerged let's first understand the
reason behind the emergence of AI data
economy is one of the factors behind the
emergence of AI it refers to how much
data has grown over the past few years
and how much more it can grow in the
coming years when you look at this graph
you can clearly understand how the
volume of data has grown you can see
that since 2009 the data volume is
increased by 44 times with the help of
social websites the explosion of data
has given rise to a new economy and
there is a constant battle for ownership
of data between companies to derive
benefits from it now that you know that
data has grown at a rapid pace in the
past few years and is going to continue
to grow let's understand the need for AI
as you know the increase in data volume
has given rise to big data which helps
manage huge amounts of data data science
helps analyze that data so the science
associated with data is going toward a
new paradigm where one can teach
machines to learn from data and drive a
variety of useful insights giving rise
to artificial intelligence now you may
ask what is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence refers to the
intelligence displayed by machines that
simulates human and animal intelligence
it involves intelligence agents the
autonomous entities that perceive their
environment and take actions that
maximize their chances of success at a
given goal artificial intelligence is a
technique that in a
people's computers to mimic human
intelligence using logic it is a program
that can sense reason and act let's look
at some of the areas where artificial
intelligence is used artificial
intelligence is redefining industries by
providing greater personalization to
users and automating processes one
example of artificial intelligence in
practice is self-driving cars
self-driving cars are computer
controlled cars that drive themselves in
these cars human drivers are never
required to take control to safely
operate the vehicle these cars are also
known as autonomous or driverless cars
let's see how Apple uses AI iPhone users
can experience the power of Siri The
Voice it simplifies navigating through
your iPhone as it listens to your voice
commands to perform tasks for instance
you can ask Siri to call your friend or
to play music serious fun and is
extremely convenient to use another
example is google's alphago which is a
computer program that plays the board
game go it is the first computer program
to defeat a world champion at the
ancient Chinese game of Go Amazon echo
is another product it's a home
controlled chatbot device that responds
to humans according to what they are
saying it responds by playing music
movies and more if you've got compatible
smart home devices you can tell echo to
dim the lights or turn appliances on or
off you can use AI and chess and here is
an example of a concierge robot from IBM
called IBM Watson the IBM Watson AI has
typically been in the headlines for
composing music playing chess and even
cooking food let's move ahead and look
at some sci-fi movies with a concept of
artificial intelligence the films
featuring AI reflect the ever-changing
spectrum of our emotions regarding the
machines we have created humans are
fascinated by the concept of artificial
intelligence
and this is reflected in the wide range
of movies on AI recommendations systems
are used by a lot of e-commerce
companies let's see how they work
Amazon collects data from users and
recommends the best product according to
the users buying or shopping pattern for
example when you search for a specific
product in the Amazon store and add it
to your cart Amazon recommends some
relevant products based on your past
shopping and searching pattern so before
you buy the selected product you get
recommendations based on your interest
and there is a possibility that you may
also buy the relevant product with the
selected product if not you have the
chance to compare the selected product
with the recommended products now let's
move ahead and understand the
relationship between artificial
intelligence machine learning and data
science even though the terms artificial
intelligence AI machine learning and
data science fall in the same domain and
are connected to each other they have
their specific applications and meaning
let's try to understand a little about
each of these terms
artificial intelligence systems mimic or
replicate human intelligence machine
learning provides systems the ability to
automatically learn and improve from the
experiences without being explicitly
programmed data science is an umbrella
term that encompasses data analytics
data mining machine learning artificial
intelligence and several other related
disciplines let's look at the flow
diagram and try to understand the
relationship between AI machine learning
and data science interestingly ml is
also an element of artificial
intelligence so the first step is data
gathering and data transformation this
step basically comes under data science
data transformation is the process of
converting data from one format or
structure into another format or
structure data transformation is
important to activities such as data
management and data integration after
gathering data we would want to use the
data to make predictions and derive
insights in order to get predictions out
of the data set we use machine learning
techniques such as supervised
learning or unsupervised learning on an
overview level supervised and
unsupervised learning are the machine
learning techniques used to extract
predictions from a given data set now
you must be thinking where deep learning
comes into the picture deep learning is
a subfield of machine learning involved
with algorithms it uses artificial
neural networks which are modeled on the
structure and performance of neurons in
the human brain deep learning is most
effective when there isn't a clear
structure to the data that you can just
exploit and build features around now
the next step in the flow diagram is to
get insights from predictions being made
in order to do so you need to use data
analysis which actually is the process
under data science now when you are done
with all of these you must want your
data to perform some actions this is
where AI comes into the picture
artificial intelligence combines
predictions and insights to perform
actions based on the human decision and
automated decision now let's move ahead
and understand the relationship between
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data science let's look at the
relationship between artificial
intelligence and machine learning
artificial intelligence is the
engineering of making intelligent
machines and programs machine learning
provides systems the ability to learn
from past experiences without being
explicitly programmed machine learning
allows machines to gain intelligence
thereby enabling artificial intelligence
let's now understand the relationship
between machine learning and data
science data science and machine
learning go hand-in-hand
data science helps evaluate data for
machine learning algorithms data science
covers the whole spectrum of the data
processing while machine learning has
the algorithmic or statistical aspects
data science is the use of statistical
methods to find patterns in the data
statistical machine learning uses the
same techniques as data science data
science includes various techniques like
statistical modeling visualization and
pattern recognition machine learning
focuses on developing algorithms from
the data provided by making predictions
so what is machine learning
machine learning is the capability of an
artificial intelligence system to learn
by extracting patterns from data it
usually delivers quicker more accurate
results to help you spot profitable
opportunities or dangerous risks now you
must be curious to understand the
features of machine learning machine
learning uses the data to detect
patterns in a data set and to just
program actions accordingly pattern
detection can be defined as the
classification of data based on
knowledge already gained or on
statistical information extracted from
the patterns it focuses on the
development of computer programs that
can teach themselves to grow and change
when exposed to new data by using a
method called reinforcement learning it
uses external feedback to teach the
system to change its internal workings
in order to guess better next time it
enables computers to find hidden
insights using iterative algorithms
without being explicitly programmed
machine learning uses algorithms that
learn from previous data to help produce
reliable and repeatable decisions it
automates analytical model building
using the statistical and machine
learning algorithms that tease patterns
and relationships from data and express
them as mathematical equations let's
understand the difference machine
learning approaches
so what is the actual difference between
traditional programming and machine
learning in traditional programming data
and program is provided to the computer
it processes them and gives the output
however the machine learning approach is
very different in machine learning
algorithms are applied on the given data
and output the result of the applied
algorithm and calculations is a learning
model that helps machine to learn from
the data in traditional programming you
code the behavior of the program but in
machine learning you leave a lot of that
to the machine to learn from data now
let's first understand the traditional
programming approach traditionally you
would hard code the decision rules for a
problem at hand evaluate the results of
the program and if the results were
satisfactory the program would be
deployed in production if the results
were not as expected one would review
the errors change the program and
evaluate it again this iterative process
continues till one gets the expected
result what is the machine learning
approach in the new machine learning
approach the decision rules are not
hard-coded the problem is solved by
training a model with the training data
in order to derive or learn an algorithm
that best represents the relationship
between the input and the output this
trained model is then evaluated against
test data if the results were
satisfactory the model would be deployed
in production and if the results are not
satisfactory the training is repeated
with some changes machine learning
techniques machine learning uses a
number of theories and techniques from
data science here are some machine
learning techniques classification
categorization clustering trend analysis
anomaly detection visualization and
decision-making let's look at these
techniques classification is a technique
in which the computer program learns
from the data input give
to it and then uses this learning to
classify new observations classification
is used for predicting discrete
responses classification is used when we
are training a model to predict
qualitative targets categorization is a
technique of organizing data into
categories for its most effective and
efficient use it makes free text
searches faster and provides a better
user experience clustering is a
technique of grouping a set of objects
in such a way that objects in the same
group are most similar to each other
than to those in other groups it is
basically a collection of objects on the
basis of similarity and dissimilarity
between them Trent analysis is a
technique aimed at projecting both
current and future movement of events
through the use of time series data
analysis it represents variations of low
frequency and a time series the high and
medium frequency fluctuations being out
anomaly detection is a technique to
identify cases that are unusual within
data that is seemingly homogenous
anomaly detection can be a key for
solving intrusions by indicating a
presence of intended or unintended
induced attacks defects faults and so on
visualization is a technique to present
data in a pictorial or graphical format
it enables decision-makers to see
analytics presented visually when data
is shown in the form of pictures it
becomes easy for users to understand it
decision making is a technique or skill
that provides you with the ability to
influence managerial decisions with data
as evidence for those possibilities now
I am sure you have a better
understanding of the overview of machine
learning so let's look at some real-time
applications of machine learning
artificial intelligence and machine
learning are being increasingly used in
various functions such as image
processing robotics data mining video
games
text analysis and healthcare
let's look at each of them in more
details so what is image processing it
is a technique to convert an image into
a digital format and perform some
operations on it
so as to induce an enhanced image or to
extract some helpful information from it
let's look at some of the examples of
image processing Facebook does automatic
face tagging by recognizing a face from
a previous users tagged photos another
example is optional character
recognition which scans printed Doc's to
digitize the text self-driving cars are
another big example of image processing
auto pilot is an optional drive system
for Tesla cars when autopilot is engaged
cars can self steer adjust speed detect
nearby obstacles apply the brakes and
park now let's see how robotics uses
machine learning robots are machines
that can be used to do certain jobs some
of the examples of robotics are where a
humanoid robot can read the emotions of
human beings or an industrial robot is
used for assembling and manufacturing
products so let's look at some real-time
applications of machine learning let's
see what data mining is it is the method
of analyzing hidden patterns in data
let's look at some of the applications
of data mining it is used for anomaly
detection to detect credit-card fraud
and to determine which transactions vary
from usual purchasing patterns it is
also used in market basket analysis
which is used to detect which items are
often bought together
it can be used for grouping where it
classifies users based on their profiles
machine learning is also applied in many
video games in order to give predictions
based on data in a Pokemon go battle
there is a lot of data to take into
account to correctly predict the winner
of a battle and this is where machine
learning becomes useful a machine
learning classifier will predict the
result of the match based on this data
let's move on to one of the most popular
applications of machine learning which
is text analysis it is the automated
process of obtaining information from
text one example of text analysis is
spam filtering which is used to detect
spam in emails
another example is sentimental analysis
which is used for classifying an opinion
as positive negative or neutral it
detects public sentiment in Twitter feed
or filters customer complaints it is
also used for information extraction
such as extracting specific data address
keyword or entities
there are many applications of machine
learning in the healthcare industry
identifying disease and diagnosis drug
discovery and manufacturing medical
imaging diagnosis and so on
some of the companies that use machine
learning have revolutionized the
healthcare industry our google deepmind
health bio beats health fidelity and
ginger dot IO
[Music]